bonjour à toutes et à tous
et désolé du retard l'invité de 5 à 10
ce matin michel branchi bonjour bonjour
à toutes et à tous vous êtes membre du
parti communiste martiniquais président
la commission finances de la 7è nous
allons aborder les élections municipales
kent à quelle analyse vous faites du
scrutin vous le pcm bon d'une manière
générale les élections municipales se
déroulent dans un contexte où lou les
municipalités de manière générale ont
subi les pertes de recettes
considérables pour la martinique
les dotations de l'état entre 2014 et
2017 et ç'a dû continuer après puisque
les chiffres le site les chiffres de
lier d'hommes ont baissé de 100 millions
d'euros
c est dans ces énormes ce qui veut dire
que les municipalités
d'ailleurs on le voit elles ont baissé
leurs investissements et on voit même
apparaître à la baisse des effectifs des
effectifs du personnel
qu'est ce qui motive qu'est ce qui peut
motiver un candidat quand on sait que
les dgf dotation générale de
fonctionnement diminuent et que tous les
pouvoirs sont passés aux op c'est ce qui
ce qui motive les candidats c'est que
malgré tout la la commune reste le
premier choix de la maison démocratie et
le contact privilégié avec avec le
citoyen et je dirais que bien entendu
les moyens ont diminué mais la nécessité
de ce dead de l'action quotidienne au
niveau du social du transport du
logement au niveau de l'accompagnement
dans les quartiers de séduction au tissu
associatif n'a pas dit mieux
bien au contraire bien au contraire et
d'ailleurs vous la voyez il est tous les
sondages montrent que l'élu le plus
populaire et le populaire dans la
hiérarchie des élus c'est de la merde
contrairement à l'hexagone il n'y a pas
de pénurie de candidats bien sûr on a
compté alors on a une centaine de
candidats tirent à bon compte alors
qu'en france par exemple il ya des
communes il n'y a pas du tout candidat
au pied des mères qui refusent d'y aller
ou démissionne même alors moi je crois
que d'abord il ya une forte identité
en martinique les gens autour de la
commune les gens quand quelqu'un
quelqu'un vous rencontre des jeunes ou
de tête d'un tueur de gargotes et non on
est à dieu je suis dangereux parce
j'aime bien mais je suis originaire moi
personnellement ma famille est
originaire du sud est lui même si je ne
vis pas où cet esprit j'ai signalé qu
football tu as politique américain qui a
joué six ans bike la fête serait soumise
à un témoin donc il ya une faute avoir
attachement à sa commune d'origine et en
martinique
je pense et puis je crois que malgré
tous les martiniquais malgré les
critiques on entend les coups de gueule
koungheul sur les radios leur clémentine
caisses sont simples que d'une manière
générale quelles que soient les courants
politiques que on a des élus qui sont
quand même au service de la population
le pcm va soutenir quel candidat
bon alors pour le moment c'est difficile
de le dire d'une manière générale les
manière générale nous savons quand même
que tout le monde pendant ces élections
du jeu je n'ai pas de couleur politique
ce n'est pas des élections politiques et
puis au lendemain des élections on va
faire le coach on va dire que la droite
a gagné quelque chose et que bon nous
nous apprécions kerman couleur nous
allons nous allons soutenir des
candidats qui d'abord une vision de la
martinique
c'est dur de la responsabilité
martiniquaise n'est ce pas et puis nous
avons obtenu deuxièmement des candidats
qui ont une priorité de du social du
soutien aux travailleurs bon alors pour
le moment c'est très difficile de
déceler
on voit au lamentin par exemple quel
candidat vous allez sedan n'a pas
discuté
pour le moment on n'en a pas discuté
parce que l'alimentaire c'est un cas
particulier vous savez très bien
l'histoire du lamentin avec le parti
communiste
c'est une commune qui nous a été
subtilisé dans des conditions moralement
ignoble et jeux et jeux et j'ai mesures
mais vous moi moi je boot rapatrie pièce
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que la
manière dont les choses se sont passées
en plus nous savons très bien que
c'était un complot derrière le cadet est
pas seulement un individu c'était un
complot par conséquent nous avons
examiné la situation bien sûr vous avez
au news on dit que quelqu'un fois ya des
bobos qui se rêve d'amener l'association
alors on va y réagirons peu le débat en
parlant d'abord de ce qui se passe en
guadeloupe et qui pourraient aussi
toucher la martinique je parlais de la
remise en cause de la prime de vie chère
et des fonctions de vice hier des fonds
versés aux fonctionnaires de la fonction
territoriale entre autres la direction
régionale des finances publiques de
guadeloupe demandent aux collectivités
territoriales de justifier du versement
de cette prime aux agents qu'elle fait
quelle est votre réaction face à ma
réaction
c'est comme pour l'autre le maire la
prime de vie chère donne de l'urticaire
à au ministère des finances
et d'une manière générale à tous les
jacobins qui dirige qui dirige la france
c'est à dire qu'ils ne supportent pas
qu'il y ait dans l'outre-mer des
dispositifs spécifiques qui tiennent
compte de l'association entre eux mais
alors c'est un ballon d'essai c'est un
ballon d'essai on essaie de voir comment
moi j'ai vu que les élus guadeloupéens
les parlementaires et les à
l'association des maires a réagi bien
très bien
est-ce qu'il faut un front commun on
peut imaginer affrontements d outre mer
10 et l'outre-mer contre
contre cette tentative tout à fait moi
je crois que ce que la le d'ailleurs à
la création des cdd 40% dans les années
cinquante a résulté préserver d'une
forte mobilisation les 40%
c'était d'abord une réaction de dignité
c'est à dire que vous aviez des
fonctionnaires français métropolitains
comme on dit maintenant qui faisait le
même travail qui touchait 65%
et puis les autochtones en tout cas à
mantes unique c'était 25 % ça venait de
la colonie alors qu'on pouvait se fait
autour de 40%
nous avons aujourd'hui je je crois que
cette cette attaque
cette attaque mérite une mobilisation
alors faudra voir bien sûr comment ça se
passe en guadeloupe
bon on dit que ce sont les titulaires il
faut que ce qu'il faut de coller commune
produisent la délibération car quand les
crampons sens et c'est contractuel aussi
sur les contractuels dont le second 115
en faut mais concernés mais en réalité
en réalité c'est une suite au coup de
sonde voir comment elle est mais j'ai lu
guadeloupéens ont très bien réagi ce
dernier thème vous l'avez déjà un peu
abordé de ce 5 à 10 et l'octroi de mer
le ministère de l'outre-mer veut
transformer cette taxe une sorte de tva
on a vu les socios plus offre
professionnelle le vent debout contre
cette modification ainsi que la ctm
quels sont les risques quelles sont les
craintes les craintes sur les chaussures
les suivantes leur toit de la mer pour
résumer les choses a deux fonctions
premièrement abonder le budget des
communes dont on voit bien que dans le
contexte actuel
bon l'ordre des martinique sé 204
millions pour les communes bien donc
dans le contexte actuel on leur a enlevé
cinq millions et l'état n'envisage pas
de remplacer les sommes qu'ils
prendraient d'un haut niveau de la tvr
et déciderait chaque année de ce qui
leur est de ceux qui l'auront re
distribuer aux communes
donc ce serait de manière
discrétionnaire ça sent la première
fonction la deuxième fonction ces deux
permettent un différentiel de taxation
entre les produits importés et les
produits locaux
or la menthe unique malgré tout un petit
secteur industriel 8500 emplois
sans cette taxation qui permet de
compenser les handicaps de compenser les
surcoûts de production puisque une somme
de petits territoires et que notamment
les coûts de production sont
nécessairement plus élevé ces huiles ce
sans emploi et puis la montagne devient
deviendrait non pas un supermarché mais
un hypermarché jeu qu'il a déjà ce
qu'elle est déjà en grande partie
revenons un peu à la politique ce sera
ma dernière question que devient le
grand ensemble et quand on voit quand on
voit que le il explose que le rdm prend
un peu de ses distances
que devient le grand slogan semblait
ciment non pas du tout le grand problème
si vous regardez les deux derniers en
plénière et eu quelques velléités de
certains de se distinguer en ouvrira
puisque on a les élections municipales
ça prouve que certains croient que c'est
en se distinguant en se singularisant et
faisant de la surenchère
on a une subvention de deals de 2000
euros le lie à quelqu'un qu'ils allaient
qui dit vos données 15000 mans ça c'est
l'apathie politique
bon le grand saut legrand semble exclue
non plus leur grand sens aller on après
qu on a 15 au monde
le grand ensemble et pour le moment je
moi je juge à la cité à blake ensemble
et le comptable et les budgets sont
votés
la dernière décision modificative numéro
3 est une division financière a été voté
la plupart des dossiers ont été votés à
l'unanimité
mercy michel bronn jso regagné terminé
bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes merci à vous tous
[Musique]